so the question everybody's asking
themselves is what is Bill Ackman doing
on this side of the pond wearing a suit
and a tie and not on vacation that's a
good question so I'm here because we
took a company public here called
Pershing Square Holdings yeah
listed on your next I think no one knows
it actually exists I even though it has
almost 7 billion of capital
it's the largest clothes I think was the
largest IPO in Europe last year
interestingly enough about a 2.7 billion
dollar IPO but it's a I would call it
the best-kept secret
you know if I came to you and I said we
have a investment holding company with
an 11-year record of compounding at 23%
compounding is equity 23% for 11 years
and you could buy it at a discount to
book value people would say well there
must be something wrong yeah and in fact
Pershing Square Holdings today trades at
about a 10% discount to book value and
if pro forma for the lower incentive
fees are purchased for holdings it's you
know part of a group of funds that have
earned that one percent for a long time
well I have a great piece of PR advice
please buy a big company in the UK make
a bang go after it and and and people
will know instantly about it is that
something that you're thinking about we
did look at Tesco I'll have to admit
that but we've had our difficulties with
retail and a lot of structural changes
going on that make it a more difficult
business we look occasionally at
companies in the UK we look at Tesco in
lastik months yes would you ring up
warren buffett and ask his advice when
you were looking at it no but when
warren buffett is giving up it's got a
lot of negative sentiment but he's
probably giving up for a good reason
but you know a lot of assets etc but we
look on it very rare occasion we were a
shareholder Cadbury prior to the crash
deal but other than that we've done
nothing here and we've not been active
in any way here I